lost amongst what went down in Super
Bowl 51 last year was the fact that Tom
Brady's mom was battling cancer and the
whole country found out about that many
ways for the first time because his mom
was at the game one of the first games
she was at in quite some time but she
was well enough to travel and watch her
son when that first ever overtime game
in Super Bowl 51 now with the rematch
coming on Sunday on NFL gameday morning
9:00 eastern time is when I'll be on the
air with Irv and Marshall and mark and
Michael and mooches they're back from
last night's big Thursday night football
game opener between the Chiefs and the
Raiders and on game day morning on
Sunday
Andrea Cramer sits down with Tom Brady's
mom and Andrea joins us now here on the
Rich Eisen show how you doing Andrea I'm
great rich how are you are you are you
anxious about tonight oh my gosh I'm
jumping out of my skin
thankfully I had this three hour show to
just help pass the time quite frankly on
that on that front I am do you root for
anybody anymore
Andrea's like a fan like no it's hard to
rich you know I think you get to the
point where you know you still love
sports but you root for the people and
the teams that are good to work with I
think that that's the safest way to to
approach it and then if you're not
working something then if you can root
for those people but yet I think I think
it gets hard if you work for the MLB
network I'm not sure know you would be
talking about how much you know no I
never did that when I was on
SportsCenter ever ever ever ever ever
but you know the one thing that they did
not mind on sports centers when you
talked about your alma mater that was
always open game if you did something
like that for you well I mean Stu was
all about the Tar Heels all the time if
you know even even left one time he
didn't do SportsCenter one night because
he did the commencement address of the
of the graduation that I think Vince
Carter went to instead of playing in a
playoff game or not being there for for
the team and a practice day during a
playoff series something like that I
remember I remember when when boomer and
KJ were doing prime time and we were
probably both still at the worldwide
leader remember how Chris used to do a
prime time player
so I I I was at a Chiefs game I my god
the guy his name is is slipping my
memory tight in for the Chiefs who went
to my alma mater the University of
Pennsylvania and he had a really strong
game and when I called in to say okay
this is what we have post game I go I
sort of said a joke and I go I think you
know Tommy gets Lou monville Chris gets
Brown I think that my guy from Penn
should get some should get some love
here and he did it he made him the prime
time player the one time that my alma
mater had any kind of notoriety in sport
was that Ross Travis or Chris Wilson or
he was those near no no I can't remember
who it is gonna drive me crazy as soon
as we get off the phone I'll figure out
what that's what texting and email and
Twitter is for let's get into what we're
gonna see on game day morning on Sunday
on the NFL Network first and first and
foremost how is Tom's mom doing Andrea
is doing well she had her left again
most recent again in August and it was
clear but as she talks about it's a very
it's a very aggressive kind of breast
cancer that she had and it's got a high
rate of recurrence and as many cancer
survivors know there's always that fear
in the back of your mind of it coming
back and she's got to manage that and
try to stay positive
though always interesting and and I
didn't realize this until after the fact
that she's never spoken publicly before
ever like this is the first ever
interview she's done and she was she was
nervous about it but I said look you
know there was so much focus last year
on Tom and on the chip on his shoulder
that he had because of deflategate but I
don't think anybody understood you know
really that the personal strain that he
was under because love him or hate him
and and we know he's probably arguably
the most polarizing player in the NFL he
has human being and he is extremely
close with his family and for his mom
who you know great tennis player golf
isn't that the cancer just came out of
nowhere for her and it was it was
shocking and if there was any silver
lining for the four-game suspension is
that he got to go home and see her
at that time something he would never
have been able to do and stayed in very
very close contact she tells the story
that they would FaceTime all the time
and she lost her hair after the chemo or
during the chemo and she would wear a
bandana and you know he would say things
to her like you know mom you look
beautiful no matter what it is and it
sounds trite but you know when you're
really sensitive about that sort of
thing to hear it from your son was very
powerful for her and she tells the story
a lot better than I just did but there
were some really moving moments sitting
down with Galen and Tom Brady senior
well why did Galen sit down for
something like this now do you think
Andrea I think because she realizes that
you know for her you know when Tom came
out and you know he never really liked
to talk about his family and when he
came out on the Tuesday of the Super
Bowl and talked about some you know
serious health challenges that his
family had those of us who had known all
along about the cancer and were really
asked to say nothing and you have to
respect somebody when when when they do
ask you to do that I was amongst those
people us as were others it was because
she was about to hopefully get to the
game they weren't even sure at that time
she was gonna be able to make it people
were gonna see her in a bandana and they
were gonna know so this idea of a very
public unveiling of your cancer and how
you handle that and how you manage that
I think that she really did this because
she wants to try to help other people
understand that there's not a stigma
attached to this and whether you are
going to be seen by millions of people
and and wearing a bandana because you
don't have any hair or you're you're not
going to look your best this is it's
it's not a death sentence and it is
something that that can be overcome and
she feels pretty strongly about that and
how important it is to truly to try to
be positive and to have hope and again
these things may sound cliche but when
you're living them they are very real
for you and it's crucial catch month in
the national
football league you know it was a over
the past several years solely focused on
breast cancer now it's many different
types of cancer that crucial crucial
catch month is about an Andrea Cramer
joining us here getting set to reveal on
Sunday's game day morning the interview
with Galen Brady and Tom senior thing by
the way rich that's interesting and you
mentioned the crucial crucial catch and
that's important is even before we sat
down with her I had no idea but the
Patriots Sunday night are honoring about
200 cancer survivors and amongst those
honored are Lexie shoulder who is the
wife of left tackle Nate shoulder whose
son Hudson had cancer as well as chatter
Shay's family and Galen brig Alan Brady
she will also be honored so it just kind
of turned out to be this this you know
strange and great confluence of events
that you know that we're gonna really
get to know her a little bit on your
show and and then she's going to be
honored later that evening so did you
see any of Tom dinner I mean where is
Tom get it from basically when you say
we kind of joked about it the
competitiveness from her Oh big time
because verse first of all I remember
when we were discussing whether or not
she was going to do this
she said hey can I can I give you a call
at at you know whatever time of a 1:30
and I said sure absolutely great
so she calls it 2:30 and she goes I'm so
sorry that I'm late
I was playing golf and I hated away hit
them so I had to go to the driving range
and and I said oh my god there's no
question where he gets his
competitiveness from is there kind of
joked about that but the reality is is
that you know the one of the ways that
she chose to approach this battle with
cancer and it was stage two when it was
diagnosed but as I said it was very
fast-growing is she was going to be
competitive about it she wanted to be
competitive with herself okay I've got
five straight months of chemo coming up
you know one down however many to go she
you know she took that attitude and and
yeah you can see that that the
competitiveness in her in pretty much
anyway even though she's
so sob spoken but he definitely he
definitely gets that from her
Andrew loved the chat again look forward
to seeing that piece on NFL gameday
morning you've got a big one on sports
gambling with real sports with Bryant
Gumbel next week as well come back
anytime okay Andrea
all right Richard's great to be on with
you thank you so much you best that you
bet that's Andrea Cramer again her
sit-down chat with the mom and dad Tom
Brady's mom and dad Galen and Tom senior
as they revealed how Galen has been
battling breast cancer and she will be
in the house on Sunday Night Football
for more Rich Eisen show tuned to
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Rich Eisen show app